hey everybody I am here missed yesterday
had an interview that went very very
long and then it was sort of going to be
a rush to stream and as you know I like
to be prepared I like to have all sorts
of material and things ready to go for
you guys so I decided to take the day
off from streaming I got very very much
caught up I achieved inbox zero which
was very very exciting and I watched a
couple episodes of Pfau de season 3
arguably the best show currently in
production and I do standby that at
least out of the five shows I watch and
very very exciting evening as all of you
can imagine what else I I do want to
issue a trigger warning I do think
anybody who is triggered by lying
deception and incompetence will find
themselves highly triggered by today's
press briefing because we do expect a
lot of that scheduled to start in about
a half hour Donald Trump tweeting that
it was pushed from 5 p.m. to 5:45 p.m.
Eastern Time which is about a 33 minutes
from right now but that gives us plenty
of time to discuss things I will tell
you about my at home blood test
momentarily but first let me just read
through a few of the super chats that
are here waiting for me it's so great to
come in and they're super chats there
it's unbelievable
Jamal Swift our friend Jamal says hey
homie I need to hear something positive
in order to preserve my mental health
any light in this tunnel today let me do
a little something for you Jamal I have
a voicemail from someone that I hope
becomes a new character on the show a
regular caller and this is arguably oh
wait a second where is this was this
yesterday this is like the sweetest it
could be it could be somebody playing a
character a voice actor but this is like
the sweetest old lady I am I'm imagining
that her name is Gladys who called into
the show every element of this is
heartwarming including the fact that my
own show is playing in the background as
she talks to me check this out this is
nice I think well this will improve all
of our moods I really
she'll and I do not think Trump is going
to worm his way out of this I just can't
even believe that he is such an idiot
and he is running our country that is
just unconscionable to me live you show
David and then it keeps playing and you
just hear my own show in the background
so I love that that I would love to
learn her name for now we are calling
her Gladys and I just a heartwarming
call it seems true to me and it's just
delightful to hear from a sweet old lady
Zachary Foster says Mike osterholm said
on MSNBC that mass PCR testing is no
longer an option with the New York
antibody tests says we need to reopen
eventually with younger adults at work
and attending events what are your
thoughts I am increasingly thinking that
there is going to have to be a paradigm
shift in how we continue to deal with
the virus
I have things planned for that Zachary
so I'm gonna get to that kevin mccomber
says will the stimulus cause inflation
interview today with stephanie kelton on
the show about that I believe the answer
is no Safra geum says thank you David
your show is the only way I can stomach
watching our tyrannical president we are
truly living in difficult times wash
your hands Kevin Macomber says what can
I say to conservatives who say Medicare
for all will would discourage medical
innovation and every other country's
relies on our innovation I mean it's
simply not true
and in fact much of the innovation I
mean listen the internet started with
government research yeah I I could go on
but it's it's just simply untrue there's
no evidence for that seth Barham says
hey David how concerned are you about
civil unrest reopening now isn't the
answer but it's going to get ugly if
there aren't more cash payments I've
said I was concerned about civil unrest
for a while
at the beginning of this and I've sort
of been avoiding talking about it
because I don't want to give people
ideas but at some point I will have to
address it in more detail I don't think
you're crazy for thinking about it Seth
BAE photo says man
yesterday would have been great for a
livestream Trump tried to force the CDC
director to walk back his statements
what are your thoughts yeah and the CDC
director said he was accurately quoted
from from what I learned it's just a
[ __ ] show it's a total [ __ ] show Jacob
Ratner says David do you meditate do you
see value in it yeah I have phases where
I will meditate every day for like three
months and then I'll fall out of it and
then I'll get back in and if I've
learned anything it's to not be
judgmental of myself for that happening
that is something I have learned from
any number of great teachers so yes I do
Chris K says I'm triggered by lies I
just can't stop watching and Charlie
says David your Bitcoin investment is
having a decent day oh I haven't paid
attention lately
but yeah I mean I definitely upped my I
upped my god I I up my Bitcoin
investment a little here's secular talk
David my phone hasn't been working so I
thought I would hit you up about voting
Biden I'd really like to have a
discussion with you about voting Biden
are you interested
so that is fake Kyle kolinsky and I love
love seeing that in the chat I'm
assuming that that is Hugh Jass / Alex
Jones / Stephen Kenneth destiny bunnell
the first or second okay let's get to
some of the the things that I wanted to
go over with you guys today before I do
that I want to say a couple of
thank-yous huge thank you to dyes often
for subscribing with twitch Prime at
twitch.tv slash David Pakman remember if
you have an Amazon Prime account you can
send me money for free you're basically
taking of a little bit of money from
Jeff Bezos and giving it to me can you
imagine a more moral this redistribution
of wealth than taking a few bucks from
Jeff and giving it to the David Pakman
show so you can subscribe with Prime at
twitch.tv slash David Pakman I also want
to say thanks to Brogan Van Schaick who
is a new member number one today at join
pakman.com we'll petty is new member
number two today
and Andre onea is new member number
three
today at join pakman.com okay let me get
into some of the things I wanted to
discuss with you guys of course our
daily update 2.7 million is the official
number of coronavirus cases globally
190,000 deaths is the number of
coronavirus deaths globally things in
the United States are not looking
particularly good we are at 876 thousand
official cases info in moments about
what the real number might be and we are
very close to 50 thousand deaths so far
we we are in a leveling that has gone
all the way back to about April 2nd now
I want to say something really important
our growth rate has been zero since
April 2nd in terms of new cases day to
day and this is something that there's a
new Israeli op-ed about that I will get
to momentarily of course active cases
are increasing but that number is
starting to grow less quickly and deaths
deaths it's not looking great I mean
again very very high death numbers over
the last few days we are essentially in
what we would call a plateau that now
has lasted about 16 days so that's that
good news on testing we've talked about
testing actual tests done need to
increase we finally have seen an uptick
in the last couple days yesterday we had
three hundred and eleven thousand tests
in a day that is by far the most that
we've ever done in one day now I don't
know why it's so much higher yesterday
but we'll track it and then today a
hundred and ninety three thousand tests
so I do believe that this is the two-day
period during which we have tested the
most three yes
we've tested almost 500,000 people in
the last 48 hours that's good news
because we need to be testing we still
need to double we've got to get to
500,000 a day that is very very good
news okay there's an article by Isaac
Ben Israel in The Times of Israel from
Israel I think we it's all cohesive as
you can understand and this is an
assertion okay I am agnostic as to
whether they're onto something here or
not
but I would love to hear from other
people and what this article asserts is
that after about 70 days the growth rate
of new cases goes to zero no matter
where it is and no matter what measures
the government imposes to try to thwart
it now this is really really important
to understand the article isn't saying
that shutdowns lockdowns quarantine
social distancing don't have an effect
it's very much the opposite the article
is actually pointing out what you do in
terms of measures will lead to more
deaths and cases or fewer deaths in
cases but the curve seems to go to
growth rate zero after roughly seventy
days they point out you can read the
article yourself they point out when you
get to new infections per day you start
to get to a period where they are not
growing you get sort of this is a really
weird ad right here by the way I don't
know if people are seeing that that's
extremely strange chiropractors baffled
I'm baffled by the ad sorry that was
distracting the point is you start to
get no new case growth they looked at a
number of days to double infections and
that starts to grow meaning that the
growth rate is slowing down they looked
at the United States and you see this
trend line that has leveled out the
United States had one set of social
distancing measures they looked at
Israel the absolute numbers are very
different but the trend line is very
very similar
they looked worldwide and okay
Worldwide's a little bit different they
looked at Italy and you see that it is a
little bit different there but it's a
very similar trend line they looked at
Sweden which has not shut down for young
people the trend line is similar so we
don't yet know what this means
and the article makes some incorrect
assertions about what Korea did for they
just get the policy wrong about what
South Korea did for example but the very
interesting thing about this article is
is that it is asserting that the growth
factor seems to be going to zero at
around the seventy day mark in case in
point I mean I'd have to
backtrack a little bit and think about
this but when you look at cases in the
United States now that we know okay so
in order to do this I actually have to
go to something else which is we now
have a report that the first coronavirus
death in the United States was not
February 29 we know of a coronavirus
death on February 6
now backtrack with me and we're gonna
I'm figuring this out in real time with
you guys if the real first death was
February 6th on average it's 17 days
from symptoms to death so you go from
you go back from February 6th 17 days
you are at about jitsi 17 11 21 January
20th okay it's roughly 2 to 14 days from
infections to symptoms meaning that the
February 6th death likely caught the
virus
somewhere between January 18 and January
6th so more than likely we had corona
virus in the US on January 6 the person
that died on January 6th according to
this article didn't have a travel
history that suggested they got it
elsewhere meaning the person who died on
February 6th who might have gotten the
virus as early as January 10th likely
got it in California from somebody else
meaning we had corona virus in the u.s.
in early January in late December okay
that makes let's just pick January 15 so
January to February is about 30 days
February to March is another 30 days 15
March 25th would roughly be day number
70 what you see here is that shortly
after March 25th in fact around April
2nd the growth rate of cases essentially
became zero every day we're finding
around 30,000 cases that is what the
article from Israel is arguing here and
it seems to be borne out by our data now
what this means about policy I have no
idea I'm not suggesting anything the
article says shutdowns should start to
be closed off I don't know that that's
the right Paul
see clearly the policies reduce the
total number of cases the total number
of deaths but the curve seems to have a
70 or 80 day cycle I don't know I don't
know that is that is what they are
asserting they're very very interesting
for sure let me say thank you to some
people on twitch donkey show has gifted
a subscription son of a shepherd has
subscribed with prime i'm expresso has
subscribed with prime master has
subscribed with prime so has de tom
diggedy the CSP and quantum scion all
have subscribed with a twitch prime if
you're joining me on facebook please
remember to hit the like button and the
subscribe button I have a number of
super chats coming in here that I want
to read Charlie so no I already read
that Matias Germany says your hair must
be so heavy it destroys your BMI yeah
because of my hair I'm technically obese
that's it that's the crazy thing unknown
prodigy says hey David how are you doing
today 1 to 10 10 being the best
pretty-pretty of a average day average
days pretty good I may be a seven and a
half or something like that yes it is
but you also okay so secular talk also
has sent messages under the name Anthony
foul G Madeline Welsh says refusing to
vote for biden because he's not as good
as bernie seems like an intellectually
dishonest position how can they say the
differences between biden and trump
aren't worth the compromise you'd have
to ask them that aligned you'd have to
ask them i don't say that shrek says hey
david this is my swamp okay Oz says any
news on the Postal Service is it still
shutting down it's still at risk of
shutting down in early June although
I've not heard anything new Kevin
mccomber says free trade or
protectionism which do you prefer way
too big of a subject to tackle
haphazardly
on a stream but I have any number any
number of clips on my youtube channel
about that Kevin Paul Newman says I
promised myself not to watch the
insanity of Trump any longer but I enjoy
you more than Trump pushes me off am I
downward spiral no participating in my
streams is never a downward spiral it's
an upward spiral thanks to Rachel for
signing up Scott Smith says protesters
lined the streets outside governor
Whitmer's residence today the organizer
was Brandon Hall he's at rumpus than has
been convicted of election fraud
protesters I believe were also at
Massachusetts governor Charlie Baker's
house today Margaret Wilson we have a
big expose on today's program about how
a lot of these protests are actually
astroturf Margaret Wilson says no one is
talking about how this virus will impact
rural areas lots of comorbidities most
doctors are immigrants especially now
with this ban yes rural areas non-white
individuals a lot of different groups
are being disproportionately affected
and we've been talking about some but
not all I have not talked about the
rural stuff quite as much but I
certainly should okay a few other things
to look at a New York Governor Andrew
Cuomo tweeted today about the results of
their first antibody tests they did
samples at 40 locations in 19 counties
preliminary estimates show a thirteen
point nine percent infection rate that's
crazy now more over look at New York
City 21% of New York City according to
this study would be extrapolated to have
had coronavirus 21% so let's do some
math 8.4 million people live in New York
City 21 per 21 percent is about just shy
of 1.8 million that's 12 and a half
times the official case rate twelve and
a half times now the more you test the
closer you are to the real test rate so
in California in LA County LA is testing
way less than New York in LA County an
antibody test I think implied a twenty
or twenty five time higher case rate
than the official rate because
California is testing away less New York
is testing more the interval is smaller
but still this would imply 12 and a half
times more people in New York City had
the virus now there's a lot of important
implications here and I'll mention a few
of them number one if
1.8 million rather than a hundred and
twenty thousand or whatever people have
had the virus in New York City it means
that the virus spreads much more easily
than we believe number two if 1.8
million people have had the virus in New
York City it means it is far less deadly
then we would believe if only a hundred
and twenty thousand people had had it
both are important things to bear in
mind number three if 1.8 million people
of New York City have had the virus it
means that our testing even in places
like New York which is testing almost
more than anybody else I think the most
in fact let's take a look where is that
let's see tests per million okay Rhode
Island is at the top but New York is
second even testing 35,000 people per
million it means that our testing is
nowhere near adequate and lastly if 1.8
million people in New York City have had
the virus it means either that they all
got infected
in February right because New York has
been locked down or the lock downs may
not be that effective we don't know I
don't know what it means but certainly
if this is accurate and there have been
there's been no shortage of problems
with the antibody tests if this is
accurate it is completely a game-changer
in terms of our understanding of the
virus and again if the lockdown does
work and somehow 1.8 million people in
New York City more than 20% got the
virus it means that they had it in
February it must have been around in
January it must have probably been
around in December mostly a
symptomatically we just don't know and
that that's the latest from Andrew Cuomo
stunning stunning numbers also looking
at the demographics slightly more men
than women getting it and that does
track with what we've seen globally for
a number of different reasons only 9
percent of the people who had it percent
positive by demographic only 9 percent
of the white population had it
now this 22 percent that says Multi none
or other I don't know how you can say
your race is none it's a little weird
but that
22% may include you know six percentage
points for white or you know whatever
but look at the racial demographics of
this also I don't incredible I think it
means maybe multiracial I don't know how
none none is weird but in any case
incredible incredible numbers out of New
York City that are up ending our
understanding of this virus incredibly
let me say a couple of other thank-yous
Mary Ellen just is new member number
four today on my website
Kristin Williams is new member number
five and Tammy Phillips is new member
number six we are counting patrons as
well I don't want to discriminate this
is not a stream that looks to
discriminate so by popular demand
website members and patrons both count
today okay other super chats that are
coming in let me make sure that I don't
miss anybody Margaret Wilson okay
Richard Botello says David which
stockbroker do you use I don't use a
broker as many people know I use
Vanguard Vanguard mutual funds are
extremely low-cost sometimes I'm paying
like four basis points on some mutual
funds and the few stocks that I hold
individually it's it's all with Vanguard
they're not an advertiser it's not a
publicly traded company I have no
financial interest whatsoever that's
just that's just who I use pine-sol says
my RN wife was exposed at work got
tested call came yesterday that she's
negative and also that the test is so
only seventy percent accurate an
unfortunate reality an unfortunate
reality Ms Smith says good to see you
back this evening thanks again for what
you do I see people confused about where
these messages are coming from these are
YouTube super chats you can send yours
there's no pre-qualification necessary
to participate you send a super chat on
YouTube and it'll eventually show up
in the lower-left their twitch messages
by the way show up in that vertical blue
box like for example 10 gig Nick grab
the twitch Prime subscription had 10 gig
Nick sent him
message it would have shown up up there
spaghetti bear did the same mean mr.
moutarde did the same etcetera etc Alex
Jones Hugh Jass and destiny says why do
you prefer single-payer over the public
option I probably have a hundred clips
about that today so unfortunately I'm
not going to fortunately for me I'm not
gonna allow you to derail the stream
Maddie I speedy why is it Massachusetts
does well with Republican governors
arguably because we have a very very
left legislature state senators and
state reps very left here in
Massachusetts Calvin Smith says respond
to Kyle's invitation for a Biden debate
it's fake Calvin it's fake
Kyle would just text me he would not
show up and pay me ten dollars to ask me
that Kaylin Brooks says hey David have
you seen how the mayor of Jacksonville
Lenny Curry is to a thousand dollars to
residents I don't know is giving money
to residents unfortunately I don't know
what you mean and I'm not familiar with
the policy AC Krause says have you seen
the CNBC interview with the German
Health Minister Yuans
spawned from ten days ago came across it
today and found it interesting haven't
seen it but I will check it out MW says
the protests in Idaho and other red
states are an embarrassment a disgrace
and purely unpatriotic to all who have
died and are currently ill Samantha Marx
has grabbed a beta level membership on
YouTube Andrew Moore says was your
interview yesterday with Joe Rogan it
was not it was not unknown prodigy says
after listening to Trump will you still
be a 7.5 no usually whatever my day
somebody earlier asked how my day is
going on a scale of one to ten wherever
I am going into one of these press
briefings I usually lose a point and a
half when I come out of the meeting
about speaking of by the way of losing
losing a point so sort of as a curiosity
but also because I'm sure I want to know
my vitamin D level from the quarantine I
got an at-home blood test for vitamin D
b12 after watching a four
our Joe Rogan debate about b12 I figured
let me test my b12 as well
I ordered an at-home test and you know
they said you just use a Lancet like for
diabetic testing of blood sugar it's
really easy and whatever so I get this
kit and it comes with four lancets and
I'm already like why would they even
include four I'm starting to not like
the direction that this is going and
brutal brutal
I was bare top I was barely able to get
any blood second one I got a little bit
more and then I had to go back to
another finger I mean it was just crazy
it probably took me a half hour to get
the amount of blood that I needed and I
have to admit they say don't squeeze the
last segment of your finger I had to do
it and I hope that that doesn't ruin the
sample in some way but I sent it out
today and I'll be reporting to everybody
hopefully by Monday I would know where
am I on vitamin D and where am I on b12
and I am NOT vegan but I don't really
eat I don't eat pork I eat very little
red meat and I'm just curious I'm just
curious
it was a pact I could have gotten I
think it was like vitamin D for 70 bucks
or a pack that included b12 and one or
two other things for like 90 bucks I
just went with the pack so we'll see how
I'm doing my my I'm expecting to score
very very highly on these tests in fact
it's possible doctors may never have
seen numbers so good on these tests
we're going to see and then I'm going to
probably take chloroquine and a z-pack
to see what that does for my vitamin D
because why and why the hell not right
what do you have to lose to quote our
great president I'm gonna have
tremendous numbers coming in okay we are
probably 5 to 10 minutes from the start
of today's press briefing by the way no
more nobody's mentioning z-pak or
chloroquine anymore I did a couple of
segments about that yesterday and yeah
it's not going particularly well for
people trying that okay a few other
super chats are coming in let's see here
in foam
minimal says briefing needs orange
Cassidy and best friends hug I just
don't know what that means
Stewie's strong says if Trump gets four
more years will you hold up I mean I
think it'll be better for my show but
bad for the country and so I'm still
voting for Biden in November because
it's the right thing for the right thing
to do
mark Fitzsimmons says is part of the
reason Massachusetts has a Republican
governor is because Democrats don't vote
in off-year elections that's an
interesting idea it turnout in off years
may be a factor I don't know enough
about it to say sands snake says I
support your right to protect but do it
from home oh it's a protest I'm sorry
the protest but do it from home well you
know it is harder to protest from home
heard about it says what do you think of
Richard Rorty I have no opinion on
Richard Rorty Alex Jones Hugh Jass and
destiny says who did you moderate in the
debate you will know this weekend my
friend a rich ropa thak says debate Sam
cedar you too classy to vote Bernie Lib
oh dear our buckle says oann equals
orange a hole news network sorry I had
to and Walter says if it becomes reality
that the virus isn't as bad as we think
as we get more data doesn't that help
trump since he'll be able to say that he
was right that it was like the flu well
what we know for sure is it spreads much
more easily than the flu because the
antibody tests that are coming in make
it abundantly clear that it spreads way
more easily than the flu there will be
other questions you know once we the
death rate certainly will be a question
and we will ultimately get that
information but I don't you know listen
the reality is I want to deal with this
in a real manner I'm less concerned
about whether it plays into this or that
thing that Trump said because the truth
so I interviewed Rachel Bittaker this
week and she argues that coronavirus is
not really going to play a role in the
election in the sense that if you think
Trump's doing a good job you were
already a sycophant who is gonna vote
for him anyway you're not going to you
know be pulled over to trump
because he's doing such a good job that
you go from being an on trumpets to a
trumpets the same time if you were not
going to vote for Trump already you're
certainly knew it's unlikely that now
you are going to be switching votes
either so Rachel bitte coffer argues
that the coronavirus thing may not
actually play that big of a role in the
election I don't I don't know if I agree
or not but she's pretty clever pretty
smart and I would certainly consider it
very strongly if that's the case still
having a the need for any number of
different ladders always some kind of
lighting issue at these press briefings
and it seems that the tech team at the
press briefing room is the most masked
up group the camera people people
running dealing with lights and and that
type of thing but always some kind of
tweak there I'm also seeing what is this
stuff that there's like rope hanging
from the ceiling I hope Trump's not
planning to hang anybody today
that would be insane if that happened
okay
let me do a one-minute interlude here
and we've been limiting these to one per
stream and it's been going okay so I'm
gonna keep limiting them to one per
stream there's this thing that a lot of
people who have YouTube channels twitch
streams etc do which is you always
pretend everything couldn't possibly be
going any better even when it's not true
and I'm not gonna do that I'm not gonna
[ __ ] you guys so I've been clear
that in because of the virus in March we
lost 389 paid members that's a lot for
us that is a lot for us I'm not gonna
lie in April so far we've probably lost
another 250 to 275 it's ugly
everybody isn't not everybody a lot Jeff
Bezos is fine but a lot of people are in
sort of a crisis mode so my ask to you
is consider getting a membership on my
website if for you a couple of bucks a
month is gonna be okay because for a
total of nearly 600 people over the last
five weeks they've had to stop
supporting us so you can go to join
pakman.com it takes under a minute for
the average user of the Internet the
coupon code 2020 now saves you 66
percent and I will thank everybody six
people have already done it and
because I'm throwing it in if you prefer
to sign up on patreon patreon.com slash
david pakman show I will still count it
it counts either way and we have
quadrupled resources on our website to
handle people who come in and try to
sign up you guys were crashing the
website previously we've quadrupled our
bandwidth on the website and it should
be more than setup to handle all of the
traffic you can throw at it
and I will absolutely make sure
everybody gets a thank you by the way I
have very exciting news for you guys
we've seen CBS News reporter away Jia
Jiang trigger Trump twice now during the
press briefings she's the one that Trump
said who do you work for take it easy
take it easy
lower your voice lower your voice
yesterday he also went at her she
followed me on Twitter guys she followed
me on Twitter that's the whole story but
it's very cool I loved it okay other
super chats that are coming in here
Walter says oh no sorry I read that
already what and now we've all scrolled
past here Alex Jones Hugh Jass and guess
Tony says I know you can't tell us who
was involved in the debate but tell us
when we will know and be able to watch
the debate we will you will know at 3:00
p.m. Eastern Time on Saturday because
that's when we are publishing it and I
will tell you it is a major major debate
in the battle of socialism versus
capitalism and I believe a huge win in
the battle of ideas if I'm perfectly
honest with you huge huge win in the
battle of ideas Donna Williams says what
do you think about a better vetting
system for presidential candidates it's
very hard to make anything law like if
you're if you're suggesting that there
should be stricter requirements for
being president it would be legally
extremely difficult to add anything
because it is constitutionally based so
to speak let me say a huge thank you to
Rachel Vander Linda who is new member
number seven today
Hector Carrillo is new member number
eight today Joe McDermott is new member
number nine and Raymond Tran is new
member number ten today I also am going
to allow Joe calfy who just doubled her
patreon pledge from five to ten dollars
a month we're counting joy as number
eleven today beautiful I love it thank
you joy very much appreciate that
Seth Barham says if you were president
would you have declared martial law by
now no and what would motivate you to I
don't know but the current circumstances
don't warrant martial law that's a
that's a major major step i Sophia
vanish yaar Dana has subscribed on
YouTube at the SOI boy level Tracey
sends a super chat Connor Brenner says
you think the lights are a trump vanity
thing yeah I mean some days Trump looks
very orange and some days he doesn't and
every day we see people messing with the
lighting in the press briefing room
maybe that's that's what that's the
connection maybe that's what it has to
do with I don't know essential says my
rough math New York State 13.9%
infections makes kovat 19 as deadly as
early estimates said approximately 1
percent still 10 times the flu yeah so
my calculation was that based on the
antibody numbers the death rate is about
0.8 the flu death rate is point 15 which
makes it about 5 or 6 times that of the
flu we have dr. Burks coming in sadly
dr. Burks is now a vector of
disinformation a trumpian vector of
disinformation it's very ugly no dr.
Burks I'm sorry no doctor foul Qi again
which is very very sad let me say thank
you to Albert Smedley whose new member
number 12 today Joel Harris is new
member number 13 Logan Carter is new
member number 14 and Hugo Richards is
new member number 15 today thanks so
much guys I so appreciate that and
during the stream the the bar will
continue to be raised so to speak when
we get started I will switch over from
the Fox feed
to the c-span feed the c-span feed is
better in a number of ways better camera
angles they show the reporters they just
start about 15 seconds late so I'm gonna
ask that you bear with me when we start
we are going to fall back about 15
seconds
but I promise you that it's all worth it
to be able to have the better produced
version that c-span puts together Jim W
has subscribed on YouTube gonzo lewd
says ICP manages to be more rational
than our government by cancelling
gathering of the Juggalos this year so
not one Juggalo life is lost I saw that
I really don't care for Insane Clown
Posse's music but they made the right
responsible decision and they must be
praised for that huge thank you to
taboos casue who has subscribed with
twitch prime also the freak has
subscribed with twitch prime with the
message
hey hey David P thank you I appreciate
that very much
Allen cave says can you interview a
local researcher Tufts Boston College
Boston University to talk more about
race inequality and kovat that's a good
idea we will look into that
Janet hunter has subscribed on YouTube
whoa vintage items store says if
unemployment goes up will Trump lose
voters it's possible alright let's get
started here we are over on the c-span
feed which is a beautiful feed in fact
it's my preferred feed and we are about
10-15 seconds behind the Fox news feed
but it's gonna be very very much worth
it as incomes Donald Trump there he is
Mike Pence as well followed by I guess a
Secret Service guy thank you very much
[Music]
later we expect the house to pass
Paycheck protection program
and health care Enhancement Act I'm
grateful that Congress is answering my
call to deliver these additional three
hundred and twenty billion dollars in
relief for the American worker and for
small businesses at a time when many
Americans are enduring significant
economic challenges this bill will help
small businesses to keep millions of
workers on the payroll you see states
are starting to open up now and it's
very exciting to see I think it's very
inspiring and we're coming out of it and
we're coming out of it well and we're
really I'm very happy the governor has
been the governor's really have been
doing a really good job working with us
and it's it's really pretty impressive
to see I've spoken to numerous leaders
of countries over the last 48 hours and
they are saying we're leading the way
we're really leading the way in so many
different ways highly doubt they're
saying well I'm also very pleased at
Harvard as you knows Harvard and
Stanford and Princeton and numerous
other universities in college as also
large businesses have bought slurring
and sent funds back to us and in some
cases I stopped funds that I looked at
and we are pleased to report that the
funds of either not gone out or it's
about three hundred and fifty million
dollars and leave it a nut gun out or
we've renegotiated it and they're not
getting them so in a couple of cases
they're sending them back and sending
them back immediately so I think it was
very nice I want to thank Harvard in
particular they acted very quickly and
decisively then they agreed when they
heard the facts that they should not be
getting it so we appreciate it very much
from Harvard Princeton
institutions the bill also includes 30
billion dollars to support small lending
institutions serving distressed
communities helping countless African
American and Hispanic American small
businesses
as we continue our battle against the
virus the data and facts on the ground
suggest that we're making great progress
in 23 states new cases have declined in
the peak week forty percent of American
counties have also seen a rapid decline
in new cases 46 states reported drop in
patients showing coronavirus like
symptoms that's a big number to keep
America gaining momentum every citizen
needs to maintain the vigilance and we
all understand that very well we've gone
over it many many times this includes
practicing good hygiene maintaining
social distance and the voluntary use of
face covering my safe and phased
reopening of our economy it's very
exciting but does not mean that we are
letting down our guard at all in any way
on the contrary continued diligence is
an essential part of our strategy to get
our country back to work to take our
country back we're winning this and
we're going to win it and we're gonna
keep watching we're gonna watch very
closely for the invisible enemy this is
meaningless stuff with each passing day
we're learning more and more about this
enemy the scientists at DHS have
released a report offering a number of
insights about how the virus reacts to
different temperatures climates and
surfaces the findings confirm that the
virus survives better and colder and
drier environments and does less well in
warmer and more humid environments I
have to say that very excitingly we're
gonna have somebody up the bill will be
up in just a little while I was a great
report you gave and he's going to be
talking about how the virus reacts and
sunlight you only hear the numbers you
won't even believe them us trials of the
kovat 19 have been going on and have
been approved trials of the kovat 19 I
think it means the vaccine kinda it's
big news and we're a lot of trials are
going on we have a lot of great
brilliant minds working on this making
it from the standpoint of a vaccine and
therapeutics we must be careful in all
conditions but
we will we will get this done we're very
close to a vaccine unfortunately we're
not very close to testing because when
the testing starts it takes a period of
time but we'll get it done and I want to
thank the head of DHS Science and
Technology bill Bryan for what he's
going to be doing and what he's going to
be saying and the report that he's about
to give I think it's gonna be something
that nobody's ever heard it'll be brand
new information if the temperature stuff
has actually I've talked to you guys
about it you would know about it from
three weeks ago it is interesting stuff
back to dramatically increase the
manufacturing delivery of critical
medical supplies we finalized three
contracts to produce 39 million more and
95 masks and 90 days and as you know
we're also using a sterilization process
some great equipment that will sterilize
the masks up to 20 times per mask so
that's like ordering 20 times more masks
and it's working very well we just want
the hospitals and the institutions where
it is to use it a lot of people don't
use it they're so used to getting a new
mask they don't want to use it they want
to go and immediately get a new one
we're asking them to use the
sterilization process every bit as good
up to 20 times think of that in addition
to ramping up our domestic assembly
lines we also have airlift at nearly 750
million pieces of personal protective
equipment into the United States through
our project air bridge which has been an
incredible thing to watch it's really a
military operation
hence loves talking vice-president is
now providing each governor with an
exhaustive count by county breakdown
come to privately distributed personal
protection and and this is equipment and
things that are incredible if it's
personal protective equipment it's
incredible and it's all brand-new and at
the highest level we're getting only the
highest level visibly struggling and
also we're looking at essential gear
within their states and is being
delivered to different states quickly
and as we speak this way the governor
should know exactly what
being delivered through a private sector
supply chain within their states as well
as through the project air bridge we're
trying to get it immediately from the
plane to the state where we can't do
that we bring it into our facilities and
get it to the governor's and we're
getting him fast and we're notifying
averse strongly so they know it's there
governor's can use this information to
quickly ensure that they get materials
where and when they are needed today I
also want to extend my special thanks to
our nation's incredible County Emergency
Management teams who have been working
relentlessly for weeks around the clock
end on end to serve their communities
help distribute critical supplies and
save countless American lives we salute
these heroic officials on the front
lines as we continue to develop
potential therapies the FDA has recently
begun a national effort to expand access
to convalescent plasma donated from the
blood of those who have like the virus
the blood of these donors contains
antibodies that can potentially reduce
the severity of the illness and those
who are sick and frankly those that are
very sick nearly 3,000 patients are now
enrolled in the expanded access program
receiving transfusions nationwide and I
want to thank all of the people that
recovered for what they've done they as
I said yesterday they raised their hand
when they barely can walk and they're
saying I want to donate blood I want to
donate whatever it is that you want we
possibly want to help people it's really
quite incredible convalescent plasma
will also be used to manufacture a
concentrated antibody treatment that
does not have to be matched with a
particular blood type this concentrated
antibody treatment could be used as a
preventative measure to keep health care
workers and other high risk populations
from contracting the virus in the first
place very big deal clinical trials of
these products are slated to begin
within weeks and we can maybe have a
fairly quick solution I urge Americans
to get in there and keep doing what
you're doing because again
we want those people recovering or
recovered from coronavirus to contact
their local blood and plasma donation
center to learn how they can help and
they've been so great and I just
appreciate it my administration is also
partnered with the leading and we have
really been establishing some great
partnerships with leading technology
companies and scientific journals to
create a database of 52,000 scholarly
articles on the virus that can be
analyzed by artificial intelligence top
AI experts are now using this wealth of
data to gain insights into potential
therapies and we're collaborating with
tech firms universities in our national
labs to harness American supercomputers
in the search for treatments and
vaccines that search is going on and
it's being I think you'll see in the
future you'll see it's very successful
ultimately it'll be a tremendous success
great progress is being made at a rapid
pace a pace like no other we have every
hope that with the full might and
resources of American science and
technology and with the courage and
devotion of the American people who have
been so incredible we will end this
plague and together we will restore the
full measure of American strength and
power and prosperity our country is
going to do fantastically well you see
what's going on yeah four million more
people lost their jobs DEP demand in our
country to get it back right where it
was and maybe even better and that's
what's going to happen so with that I'd
like to ask Mike Pence to come up nice
presidents say a few words please Mike
so we mute pens because he contributes
nothing of value and it's aggressively
it's it's weaponized disinformation so I
mute pens I actually I do want to hear
the stuff about the temperature and
humidity because of course Trump is
going to pretend like this is something
he came up with or he thought I mean
it's just it this has nothing to do with
Trump but there are a number of papers
that look at the combination of
temperature and humidity and its effect
on the virus there's a question of
sunlight and UV rays and its effect on
the virus there may be something to that
it's not a miracle but if the contagion
the facility if the facility of
contagion goes down even a little bit
because of changes to temperature and
humidity you the those changes become
cumulative and it can make a real
difference and this is part of why in
areas where the flu is seasonal why it
is seasonal and I actually am really
looking forward to hearing what they
have to say about that just out of
curiosity know we were muting pence he
says nothing of value but I'm gonna
check in and see if he's doing his usual
sick of fancy extent saving lives our
task force actually believes mr.
president that if we can yep it's
exactly it's exactly what we thought so
yeah he's doing it so don't worry what
will go back when important things
happen I do want to say thanks to Daniel
Smeltzer who is new member number 28
today and Eric Feist who is new member
number 29 you folks are all much more of
a pleasure to listen to than is the the
vice president here I did so
tomorrow on the show I got a bunch of
people who emailed me about the Las
Vegas Mayor being interviewed by
Anderson Cooper and it's a complete and
total mess and I reviewed the video and
it is indeed a complete and total mess
and I'm going to be talking about that
on tomorrow's program and we'll have a
clip about that probably Friday Saturday
it'll be published on YouTube it's
really crazy and I even I even had it
here we could have looked at it I don't
I want to make sure that I'm here for
when Mike Pence is done talking but it
is really really crazy the other thing
on on treatments that Donald Trump is
talking about obviously you've all
probably noticed by now that Trump is no
longer talking about chloroquine
chloroquine is something he was
promoting early like a miracle drug dr.
oz was talking about it on Fox News we
were here you know all sorts of people
Fox some friends was talking about it
for the last week we've had study after
study say it doesn't seem to be helping
and and people may even be dying at a
higher rate when they are given a
chloroquine regimen when they have
coronavirus with or without the z-pak
different modalities as Donald Trump has
been saying we don't hear them talk
about chloroquine anymore it's like it
doesn't exist anymore
and unfortunately the latest Ramdas aver
test which is a drug made by Gilead
Sciences Sciences the latest test I saw
with that also didn't go particularly
well so I still have a cautious optimism
that by the fall we are going to have
some therapeutic that that works ok at
least it's just not clear what it's
going to be a began also known as fovea
vert which is a Japanese drug is being
tested maybe there's something there
there's a combination of two HIV
medications being tested that's
interesting there's the idea of there it
is being tested the polio vaccine and
the tuberculosis vaccine the idea is not
that they might vaccinate you against
coronavirus but the idea is they might
cause the exact type of immune response
that might reduce the likelihood of you
contracting coronavirus and so those are
being looked at and then there's a whole
bunch of other things under development
and other things being considered
there's a ton of this stuff and so the
responsible thing from the beginning
would have been for Donald Trump never
to kind of emotionally get behind one
drug but to say there's a whole bunch of
stuff that we're trying you would have
had fewer people going out and trying to
obtain chloroquine you likely would have
had a a fewer of the tragic side effect
related incidents that we've had which
have been very very ugly I want to say
thanks to Colby Barrett
Colby Barrett is new member number 30
today at join pakman.com thanks Colby I
very much appreciate it
Trump has already spoken as a matter of
policy we mute Mike Pence because he's
just so vile and toxic and says the
exact same thing every day but we are
expecting next a briefing about the
possible impact of temperature and
humidity changes in the United States on
the virus and that is a very interesting
thing now very early Donald Trump said
something like when it gets warm this
will disappear we had no evidence of
that at the time and I've still seen no
evidence of that what we do have some
early studies suggesting is that as
the country warms both the temperature
and humidity but also potentially the
additional UV light from the sunlight
may all be detrimental to the virus's
ability to survive and that would be a
really great thing again as a respite
until the fall at which time every
serious epidemiologist including doctor
foul Chi infectious disease expert is
expecting a wave to wave to sometimes is
as bad or worse as wave 1 and the the
coronavirus wave 1 started late in the
flu season late December early January
by our earliest our best estimates right
now that probably helped this first wave
not be as bad the second wave which
again will almost certainly happen could
be even worse and that's why we need to
be able to much more quickly put
measures in place hopefully have an
early emergency use vaccine for
healthcare workers by October that's a
possibility if things go well it's a
real possibility won't be wide
widespread availability but for health
care workers on an emergency basis and
hopefully having some kind of treatment
that by then has been shown to be
relatively efficacious with reasonable
side effects because some of the ones
being tested so far including Trump's
favorite chloroquine significant side
effects so far
super chats are coming in Chris is
asking whether other countries are
having successes with vaccines or
therapies yeah other countries are
seeing very similar things to what we
are seeing there are dozens and dozens
of vaccines under development globally
right now and to say successes I mean
you know other countries are
investigating a lot of the same things
that we are - make says bueller bueller
yes
Christopher click says yet Ashford
hospitality a major Trump donor pockets
30 million in PPP funds after
terminating or furloughing 95% of their
7,000 employees yeah there's the idea
that the Harvard thing making Harvard
give the money back that it's
essentially a distraction
tactic to take attention away from tons
of less well-known organizations and
companies that have received money that
arguably should not have that's that's
the idea that's floating around Black
Mac Miller says hey David how much do
you read a day I read at least 25 pages
of a nonfiction book usually closer to
40 and then I also at night will read
some fiction book that I'm reading
probably another 25 pages or so so my
daily reading it's not what I would like
but it's probably between 40 and 75
pages on average in some kind of average
sense as we wait for Mike Pence to
finish up here I also want to thank
Linda short for signing up at join
pakman.com Linda you are new member
number 31 today
31 a terrific number absolutely terrific
number and I really appreciate everybody
who's been signing up and supporting
let's check in on pence he should be
winding down Trump doesn't really like
him going this long usually a few days
that will consist of four phases and
require specific criteria that Idaho and
businesses need to need to begin to
reopen oh he's rapping mr. president
with the with the guidelines to open up
America again states are making plans
and at your direction our task force
will continue work very closely
providing them with the data providing
them with the resources to be able to
implement those plans summarize this
states will soon open masks airbridge
scheduled flights leadership thank you
risk that we are seeing is a testament
to what all of you have done to our
extraordinary health care workers a
partnership between the federal
government and to state and local
official and and I'm confidence also
owing to the prayers of millions of
Americans each and every day all of that
combined we're we're slowing the spread
we're protecting the most vulnerable
we're saving lives and in every single
day we are one day closer to opening up
America
again with that mr. president I'd be
pleased to call bill forward
yes that's what we want all right the
leads the Science and Technology
Directorate at the Department of
Homeland Security and now we'll make a
presentation on their recent study Thank
You mr. vice president I think we must
listen up here for this opportunity to
do this today good afternoon everybody
my name is Bill Bryan and I lead the
Science and Technology Directorate at
the US Department of Homeland Security
over the last several months we've
intensified the department's iron D
efforts to identify and deliver
information that informs our response to
covert 19s MT is working to identify
develop deploy and deploy the tools and
information to support our response to
this crisis as part of our efforts we're
leveraging the unique capabilities of SM
T's national bio defense analysis and
countermeasures Center L boy just study
the biology of the Cova 19 virus this
may be worse than I expected I don't
know I biocontainment laboratory located
in Frederick Maryland it was established
in the early 2000s in response to the
Ameri tracks attacks and where we
studied characterize analyze and develop
countermeasures for biological threats
to the homeland we work closely with the
CDC FDA HHS and also our Department of
Defense colleagues and many others right
yesterday I shared the emerging results
of our work that we're doing now with
the coronavirus task force and today I
would like to share certain trends that
we believe are important if I may have
the first slide please and while that's
coming up our most striking observation
to date is the powerful effect that
solar light appears to have on killing
the virus both surfaces and in the air
we've seen a similar effect with both
temperature and humidity as well we're
increasing the temperature and humidity
or both is generally less favorable to
the virus so let me illustrate with this
first slide if you look to the right
you'll see that term half life with a
bunch of time stamps on there first let
me tell you what a half-life is we don't
measure the virus as far how long will
it live on the surface we have to
measure the decay of the virus in terms
of its half-life because we don't see
certain elements we don't know how much
a person expect rates Winnie Winnie the
Spitz right when you sneeze
whatever the case may be we don't know
how much virus is in there so it's that
that has a long bearing on how long the
virus is going to be alive and active so
we measure in half life because half
life doesn't change so if you look at an
18 hour half-life what you're basically
saying is every 18 hours the virus the
life of the virus is cut in half so if
you start with a thousand particles of
the virus in 18 hours you're down to 500
in 18 hours after that you're down to
250 and so on and so forth that's
important as I explained the rest of the
chart if you look at the first three
lines when you see the word surface
we're talking about non-porous surfaces
door handles stainless steel and if you
look at as the temperature increases as
the humidity increases with no Sun
involved you can see how drastically the
half-life goes down on that virus so the
virus is dying at a much more rapid pace
just from exposure to higher
temperatures and just some exposure to
humidity if you look at the fourth line
you inject summer the sunlight into that
you inject UV rays into that the same
effects on line two at 70 to 75 degrees
with 80% humidity chart please on the
surface and look at line four but not I
could explain why things are so crazy in
Massachusetts despite all the measures
were taking and assuming Florida is
telling the truth it's not as bad there
this could actually be a big factor in
it capability I was discussing this with
the president prior to coming out he
wanted me to convey it to you on how we
do this I believe we're the only lab in
the country that has this capability but
if you can imagine a home depot bucket a
five gallon home depot bucket we were
able to take a particle and this was
developed and designed by our folks at
the end back we're able to take a
particle of the virus and suspend it in
the air inside of this drum and and hit
it with various temperatures various
humidity levels multiple different kinds
of environmental conditions to include
sunlight and we're able to measure the
decay of that virus while it's suspended
in the air this is how we do our air
assault testing we worked with John
Hopkins Applied Physics lab and we
actually developed a larger drum to
actually more testing as four times the
size of that so this is the capability
that we bring to this effort
so in summary within the conditions
we've tested today
the virus in droplets of saliva survives
best in indoors and dry conditions the
virus does not survive as well in
droplets of savate saliva and that's
important because a lot of testing being
done is not necessary being done
number one with the Koba 19 virus and
number two in saliva or respiratory
fluids and thirdly the virus dies the
quickest and the presence of direct
sunlight under these conditions and when
you when you look at that chart look at
the aerosol as you breathe it you put it
in a room 70 to 75 degrees 20 percent
humidity low humidity it lasts the
half-life is about an hour but you get
outside and it cuts down to a minute and
a half very significant difference when
it would truly raise huge if through mr.
president while there are many unknown
links in the Cova 19 transmission chain
we believe these trends can support
practical decision making to lower the
risks associated with the virus if I can
have my next slide and when that caught
while that comes up you'll see a number
of some practical applications for
example increasing the temperature and
humidity of potentially contaminated
indoor spaces appears to reduce the
stability of the virus and extra care
may be warranted for dry environments
that do not have exposure to solar light
we're also testing disinfectants readily
available we've tested bleach we've
tested isopropyl alcohol on the virus
specifically in saliva or in respiratory
fluids and I can tell you that bleach
will kill the virus in five minutes
isopropyl alcohol will kill the virus in
30 seconds and that's with no
manipulation no rubbing just bring it on
and leaving a go you rub it and it goes
away even faster we're also looking at
other disinfectants specifically looking
at the covert 19:00 virus in saliva this
is not the end of our work as we
continue to characterize this virus and
integrate our findings into practical
applications to mitigate exposure and
transmission I would like to thank the
president thank the vice president for
their support good presentation I just
want to remind you guys I talked about
this two weeks ago this is not new
information but you know Trump of course
loves to act as if this is all breaking
news R&D community thank you very much
so I fell a question that probably some
of you are thinking of if you're totally
into that world which I find to be very
interesting yeah so supposing we hit the
body with a tremendous whether it's
ultraviolet or just very powerful light
and I think you said that hasn't been
checked but you're gonna test it and
then I said supposing you brought the
light inside the body you can which you
can do either through the skin or in
some other way
tanning bed and I think you said you're
gonna test that too sounds interesting
right and then I see the disinfectant
weird knocks it out in a minute one
minute perks and is there you can't do
something regret by injection inside or
almost of cleaning because you see it
gets in the lungs and it does a
tremendous number yeah launch it I just
know that you have to use medical
doctors with a chance it sounds
interesting to me God so we'll see but
the whole concept of the light the way
it kills it in one minute
that's that's pretty powerful extend the
social distancing guidelines until then
we may go beyond that we're gonna have
to see where it is and I think people
are gonna know you're gonna know I'm
gonna know I think people are gonna know
just that a common sense at some point
we won't have to do that but until we
feel it's safe we're going to be
extending you have 23 cases where new
cases in 23 states where new cases are
on the client what does that mean about
when the country can be safely reopened
to a normal point yeah but it means
we're gonna watch those cases very
carefully I think we've all gotten very
good at it we've gotten good at tracing
we see where the cases are where they're
going and we're gonna be watching it and
it's called containment at a certain
point we're going to be able to contain
and you know when you see this a lot of
people have been talking about summer
maybe this is one of the
we've I once mentioned that maybe it
does go air with heat and light and
people didn't like that statement yeah
oh my god fake news didn't like it at
all and I just threw it out as a
suggestion but it seems like it wasn't
he's lying he said it'll go away with
the summer nothing to worry about it was
the part of the the defense of doing
nothing for a whole bunch of time dives
very quickly with the Sun yeah go ahead
you said yesterday that you're gonna
look into Senator McConnell's suggestion
for a lot States to declare bankruptcy
versus the aim yeah we'll look into it
and I've been looking into it I've been
talking to a lot of the different
senators but I don't want to talk about
it now that was a very interesting
presentation go ahead just why I wanted
to talk about McConnell suggestion than
eight to the States amounts to if I just
tell you I'm not talking about them all
talk about it later
I'd like to talk about something that
has more interest if they ask mr. Bryant
yes you
your car thank you when you started your
presentation you described this as an
emerging result does this mean your
study is conclusive is there more work
to do
we're continuing that for example on the
aerosol side you notice the figures were
twenty percent humidity we're looking at
higher humidity levels would expect that
we even have a greater impact on the
virus we're looking at other types of
disinfectants and and so we're this is a
we're as a scientific community where
the continuing to study the virus to
understand its characteristics seen in
the US are hot and humid like New
Orleans for example let me explain if
you look at the corona virus as a chain
with many links well we've done through
our study is we've identified some of
the weak links in that chain that the
virus the transmission of the virus
depends upon we identify that heat and
humidity is a weakness in that chain
we've identified that sunlight solar
light UV rays is a weakness in that
chain that doesn't take away the other
activities the guidance from the White
House the guidance from the CDC and
others on the actions and steps that
people need to take to protect
themselves this is just another another
tool in our tool belt alright another
another weapon in the fight that we can
add to it and in the summer we know that
summer-like conditions are going to
create an environment where the
transmission can be decreased and that's
an opportunity for us to get ahead the
president mentioned the idea of cleaner
complete race equality there's no
scenario that could be you know I I'm
here to talk about fine that we had in
the study we don't of course you're not
going to believe
rejection almost paid claiming
sterilization of an area maybe it works
maybe it doesn't work but no injecting
we're not gonna work effect pivots on
the stationary object two months by
saying that it'd be better with the
warmer weather and the Sun coming out
more and more people would be outside
and stay inside their homes it would be
irresponsible for us to say that we feel
that the summer is just gonna totally
kill the virus and then if it's a free
for all and that people ignore those
guys that is not the case we we have an
opportunity though to get ahead with
what we know now and factor that into
the decision makings picked up now what
what's not being mentioned is what
percentage of this is being transmitted
through surfaces and it's suspected that
it's not that that much most of the
transmission is not happening because
someone touched something and then I
come an hour later and I touch it
there's it doesn't seem like that's the
majority of the transmission this entire
conversation mostly deals with that it
could still be there right it has to be
indirect light of the UV rays right and
their hands are exposed to the Sun will
that kill it as though it were a piece
of metal or something else not I don't
want to say it will at the same rate
because it's a non-porous service but we
do know what we do know din is very do
that we looked at the worst-case
scenario and the virus lives longer on
non-porous surfaces so porous surfaces
it doesn't live quite as long so in
theory what you said is correct this is
a
right yes mr. houses governors who are
opening their state's working on that
incorporate the findings of this study
into those guidelines I would leave that
up to the governor's this is a this is a
decision this factors into their
decision process as I mentioned with
knowing this knowledge and having this
knowledge as we continue to study and
further know what the virus does in how
it reacts it could impact the way a
governor will look at what he opens in a
state how he opens it he and what
environments these things are opened up
but I leave that up to the governor's to
make that decision obviously remember
the advice is stay at home by the summer
could we be flipping that and saying
you'd be much better off being outside
with UV rays or the humidity that
Washington brings in August I would not
go contrary to the gains that have been
issued right now I think though to tell
you that if if I'm having an event with
my family I'm doing it in the driveway
or in the backyard not inside the house
how much more research how much more
time would it take to have a conclusive
we we first were able to receive the
virus back in February is when we
started testing and it is a
science-based approach science is a
process and the doctor can attest of
that
it doesn't necessarily line up with
goals and targets and other things it is
what it is but we are now starting to
get results and and where every week or
two weeks we're starting to find out
something new and something different
and in talking to the to the task force
and the vice-president he's already
asked us to come to him every time we
come up with some new discoveries that
would could be that we could share to
the public yes sir have you compare
notes with your counterparts and other
foreign governments or in private
industry who might have been studying
the same thing and do their findings
show the same result that you found here
we have we do have a very good
partnership with a lot of our allies we
work closely with them on this
particular topic
we actually authored a document call the
master questions list but if you go to
DHS S&T website root i've already had
about 17,000 hits on this document it
actually outlines with all the countries
in the world are doing to fill the
certain gaps of knowledge that don't
exist within the virus and what we do
know and that is really what targets and
drives the science community state what
don't we know now so we don't duplicate
what other people have done
so we've championed that document it's
well referenced and I would encourage
you to look at that and we are working
with other countries on vaccines
with this virus what would the federal
government need to do to take advantage
of that time oh so if there is a summer
sort of ed with this virus
what would the diplomat that it needs to
do to take advantage of that time to be
better prepared for a possible
resurgence in the fall that we were the
personality one thing I think a lot of
people are gonna go outside all of a
sudden people that didn't want to go
outside they'll be guards is that to me
this was very really a very interesting
meeting we've covered in great detail
and these are incredible people you've
got that we could call it a laboratory
because that's essentially what it is
what's going on it doesn't know the
things going on so he's having to just
dance around interesting things
what would you in other areas the
government needs to do on testing for
example or other things like that to be
prepared that came back in the hole why
would you take advantage over supper
that's it's actually a very good
question as something to test for sardis
you had to bring in pens yeah discussing
that we are if a combination of factors
let me say again as States put into
practice at the guidelines to open up
America again implement a safe and
responsible plan not to open up their
economies along the lines that the
president unveiled a week ago today as
people continue to properly exercise
social distancing as as is recommended
in each phase that in combination with
some of these findings could well give
us summer respite from the coronavirus
and our team is already speaking about
working on a continuous basis through
this summer every single day were
increasing testing every single day air
bridge flights are coming into the
country there I I can promise you at the
president's direction there will be no
light in the last two days testing did
go up but we had most of April during
which it did not it essentially stayed
steady affective supplies for medical
personnel
they'll be no letting up on the
development of therapeutics by our great
pharmaceutical companies are driving
toward a vaccine as soon as it is
possible to make available to
public and there'll be no letting up on
continuing to scale testing already more
than anyone in the world but Vox capita
will have a broad range of testing a
variety of different means and that's
why we say anything you took should the
corona virus re-emerge at any point next
fall or next winter we will be prepared
to deal with it identify it do the
contact tracing and isolation to ensure
that we're not currently we are deal
with this hopefully we will be by then
in the manner that we that we deal with
infectious diseases medical research why
have you stopped promoting Hydra yeah
what do you say if we'll see what
happens
we've had a lot of very good results and
we had some results that for absolutely
I don't know I just read about one but I
also read many times good so I have a
new record and I'd say it's a great for
malaria for lupus for other things so
what it is but no yes Deborah they have
many many studies going on on that so
will will be able to billion that guys
claims over five weeks yeah how the vice
president talked about this summer
getting better about how what do your
economists tell you about the time it's
gonna take lead to you in the u.s. to
October well let me go the week we know
the rest of the question right so I
about economists and the answer is they
have no idea I think I have as good an
idea as anybody and I think our economy
will start to pick up very substantially
as soon as those states Karen is right
that economists are terrible at
predictions whether he's any better I
don't know but economists are very bad
at predictions he said something true
finally because our country has to get
back to work they want to get back to
work you see that whether it's a
demonstration or just in talking to
people they're going to get back to work
and they're gonna get back to work very
fast states are advanced
I look at Gavin Newson was dissin was
very nice today he wrote a beautiful
statement about we sent him a lot of a
lot of things that he needed yeah okay
so the guy who asked the question about
chloroquine that's Phillip Rutger he's
the one who wrote the book of very
stable genius and that that may be why
Trump looked disgusted when he started
to speak dark in New Jersey got hit very
hard you're doing very well I spoke
again with Governor Cuomo with governor
Murphy they're doing they're doing a
great job and here's the thing we have
to see they got hit hard
everyone close together tight end people
don't realize New Jersey is very tight
you realize that because you've been
covering it for a long time but very
tight New York obviously is very tight
they're doing a terrific job I think for
the most part I'll be able to tell you
when it's all over but a lot of the
governors have done a really terrific
job some I don't think have to be honest
but we'll be talking about the future
yes go ahead interview today with Time
magazine doctor Gao Qi say oh that the
US is not in a situation where we can
say we are really want to be with regard
to testing capacity he said we need much
more testing computer buzzing figures as
well as tests so why do you keep saying
we have a tremendous testing capacity
and do we have a national strategy that
goes beyond track you just what the
states are doing yes yes and the
interests as you know and as I've said
many times we're very advanced and
testing other countries are calling us
to find out what are we doing but no one
would show some numbers and you'll see
different forms of testing just like we
came up with the Abbott Laboratories
machine which gives it to you in five
minutes that everybody wants everybody's
asking can we get that but you can only
make them so firmer he talks about as
you know we've done more testing than
every other nation combined not per
capita that's a big statement and you
know when they talk about different
tests and different things we're also a
bigger nation than most
that's why per capita so when they look
at statistics because statistically
we're doing phenomenally 42nd terms of
mortality in terms of all of the
different elements that you can judge
when you look German or tality were 14th
highest in the world per capita we are
very accurate in the reporting of
numbers in fact I'll go a step further
as you know in New York they actually
added quite a few deaths to a list that
was done in New York and they added a
number of deaths were very very highly
accurate I look at certain lists of
other countries some are so obvious just
to look at where obviously the number is
ridiculous in the form of low because
they're not accurate counts they're not
even close to accurate counts in fact
they're insulting to look at them so
we've done very well again testing we're
doing very well on testing we've tested
far more than anybody else anywhere in
the world at the line and within a short
period of time you'll be hearing about
new tests that are coming out that are
gonna be incredible we're just not there
no I don't agree with him on that no I
think we're doing a great job when
testing I don't agree if you said that I
don't agree with them yeah considering
ways to get the to ramp up production of
that Abbot rapping no while they're
doing it I'll tell you Steve they're
doing it at a level that they've never
done it before it's actually heart rate
you come with lies very big highly
respected company they came up with this
machine where you do it I've done it
both ways I've done it this way and I
didn't like it and I've done it the
Abbott way where you literally just
touch and five minutes later you know
the answer and we use them in the white
house I think you folks have been given
that opportunity which is much more
pleasant than the first way that they
looked at you right we're making them
hundreds of thousands of machines the
advantage to the other test and the
laboratory test so we can get millions
and millions of those tests done it
takes a day or two days but you know
because it's really a delivery situation
more than anything else the test itself
goes quickly once it gets to the
laboratory but as we have found and as
we have I think she'll never get in
there
have many laboratories we have that we
have so many laboratories nobody nobody
a lot of the governor's did not know
that we have this capacity but we have
many laboratories all over our country
every state has laboratories and some
have a lot of them so I think we will we
will come up with things as time goes by
again when I started we ended up we
started with nothing essentially what we
started with a broken test a test that
didn't work we started with a tested
very few people not millions of people
remember this is like weirdly playing
about blaming Obama for not having some
kind of test for something that didn't
exist when Obama was president it's
crazy the media would say oh you should
have done two for each person no matter
what you do it doesn't make any
difference it's just like the ventilator
as I talk about it all the time nobody
ever mentions ventilators one of the
hardest things uh ventilators and now
we're making thousands a week thousands
of ventilators and they're calling from
Mexico they're calling from many
countries I've received today four calls
would it be possible to send ventilators
right I get four calls today I got three
calls yesterday no country is equipped
like we are we have 11 we have 11
different places making ventilators our
country as you know doesn't need them
now our governors are very happy but
that's different than tests because with
the test you can always say oh we need
one no I think we've done incredibly
well with obviously with ventilators it
would we also have 500 million masks 500
million masks that are very shortly
going to be here we've really Hammond's
of masks we have ordered millions of
myths that have arrived and been
distributed we gave one Hospital in New
York City 300,000 masks before the virus
they were using 10,000 and now we got
them 300,000 and they got rid of them
very quick which quickly which I sort of
say how did that happen why because they
became very valuable the masks so I say
how did that happen
but we got we have we've done an amazing
job and we've worked with the governor's
and when the governor's weren't able
again they're the first line when they
weren't able to get something like
ventilates they couldn't get ventilators
they could have bought him you could
have bought him but most of them many of
them chose not to so they all needed
ventilators we got the job done
everybody did the wrong have I'll be
introducing the team when we're finished
with this whole nightmare this whole
curse this whole plank but the team that
worked on the ventilators was incredible
and the team that work it's a little bit
interchangeable but the team that's
working on the testing is truly an
incredible team these are brilliant
people and they're doing it for the
country they're not doing it for other
reasons some have been very successful
they're doing it for the country the
house is not past that you were here the
relief billing understanding it probably
tonight as you know there's no aid to
states and localities in that bill Mitch
McConnell of course has talked about
States seeking bankruptcy protection
he's also his office refer to this is a
the idea of aiding States is a blue
state bailout what do you say to that do
you do you agree with that or you agree
with Governor Cuomo that that is a a
vicious attack on these states dashas
attack but certainly some people do look
at it that way I've spoken to Mitch
about it I've spoken to numerous
senators about it and we're working with
senators that are on the other side of
the issue and we'll see what happens but
this hope we look at a bailout thing
it's like this is a people bailout
there's more people in New York right in
New York has 8.4 million people so they
need more and it happens to be a blue
state but it's a people bailout in all
fairness John some states have not done
very well for many years so long before
the virus came you know you can't blame
the plague this horrible plague that
came in and all of a sudden you know
they can't blame that you look at
Illinois now he's got a lot of problems
long before the virus came in and so
we'll be talking about it it'll be a
subject for a period of time and right
now we've we've made this incredible
deal for the workers and for small
business and I'm very happy that Harvard
didn't get covered
actually never sent them to check right
but they were very nice about there was
no money sent back the the money the old
fashioned where's the check the new way
has sent him the money and we didn't
send him the money and but they were
very understanding and they were very
nice about it so is Princeton so with
Stanford so were a number of other
schools that you just don't associate
with this money
so we're big companies as you know you
know many of them it was a relatively
small amount of money compared to the
hall very small amount of money compared
but we want it to be fair we want it to
go to the people that are supposed to go
to ideas that are gonna be great for the
people of this country and if we can
help States we're always gonna help
States now there's different ways of
helping States some ways are better than
others so we're looking it is
interesting that the states that are in
trouble do happen to be blue it is
yesterday morning if you look around I
mean the states and things that have the
problem happened to be Democrat and
Jersey got hit by this you know long
before the plane populated you know they
had a lot of problems long before the
play came I spoke with Governor Cuomo
Bevin spoke so let me interject his this
isn't this is an important yoga you guys
may come across this from weaponized
disinformation sources in the future
they love to say there's the sky charlie
Kirk okay he's on Twitter saying crazy
stuff they say you know the the ten
cities that are worst off financially
the mayor's are all Democrats
it's like cities are more democratic
than they are Republican so it's just a
self-selection bias that's what happens
in cities is it dangerous for you to
make people think they would be safe by
going outside in the heat
considering that so many people are
dying in Florida considering that this
virus has had an outbreak in Singapore
places that are line and are we get a
new headline is trumpets people to go
outside that's dangerous
here we go same old group you ready I
hope people enjoy the Sun and if it has
an impact that's great I'm just hearing
this not really for the first time and
there's been a rumor that you know a
very nice rumor did you go outside of
the Sun or you have heat and it does
have an effect on other viruses but now
we get it from one of the great
laboratories of the world I have to say
covers a lot more territory than just
this this is this is probably an easy
thing relatively speaking for you I
would like you to speak to the medical
doctors to see if there's any way that
you can apply light yes and heat to cure
you know if you could and maybe you can
maybe you can't again it can maybe you
can do I'm not a doctor but I'm like a
person that has the food you know
whatever have you ever heard of that the
heat and the light oh yeah yeah yeah
relative to eat lamps certain viruses
yes but relative to this virus that is a
treatment I mean certainly fever
is a good thing when you have a fever it
helps your body result but not as I've
not seen yes you look at okay people
tuning into these briefings they want to
get information and guidance and want to
know what to do they're looking for a
murder
I'm the president and you a fake news
and you know what I'll say I'll say very
nicely I know you will I know you well
because I know the guy I see what he
writes he's a total faker so are you
ready are you ready are you ready it's
just a suggestion from a brilliant lab
by a very very smart
perhaps brilliant man I'm talking about
son he's talking about heat and you see
the numbers so that's it that's all I
have I'm just here to present Talent
I want to present ideas off the truck
because we want ideas to get rid of this
thing and if he is good and if sunlight
is good that's a great thing as far as
I'm concerned is down down
talk to me a moment ago about magazines
that we're close how close do you think
the Oxford University study says they
could have won by September do you think
the pharmaceutical companies in the US
or rather if we have one of one have a
vaccine ready
that's the Oxford's one Johnson &
Johnson is working they're also working
together you're many companies working
together on a vaccine then if you think
that scales they can scale up production
and in pharmaceutical companies would be
able to do that quickly we had a vaccine
it'll be scaled up very quickly in fact
yes now some of the companies Johnson
and Johnson as one is scaling up already
before they have the final answer in
fact know how companies are doing they
just have a lot of time their normal is
you scale up after I have to say the FDA
has been fantastic
Stephen Han dr. Hahn has been fantastic
they're moving along rapidly scaling it
Lee would you say time scale when not -
time scale because then the the media
the so-called so-called media lamestream
media will say he said a time I don't
want to say times because every time I
say a time if you don't hit it they'll
say so I don't want to talk about that
but I will say that there's been
tremendous progress made over the last
month
can I just ask a very quick question you
spoke to Boris Johnson this week is
wonder how he sounded how he was when
you think every packet would called me a
few days ago I will tell you he sounded
incredible I was actually surprised I
thought it'd be like Oh Donald how are
he but he's not like you know I could
I'm very surprised to tell you this it's
like the old Boris tremendous energy
tremendous Drive I was very surprised
because he called me almost you know
pretty close to when he got out of the
hospital right I think he's doing great
I think he's doing great he was so sharp
and energetic pretty incredible he's an
incredible guy he's a friend of ours and
and a friend of mine he loves our
country he loves his country a lot of
course but he loves our country respects
our country and they're lucky to have
them over there please
a couple days ago said that you might
reach out to Tim gentleman directly but
also that you were working to find out
if those reports about him being
impossible medical trouble were true I'm
wondering if you've either hope he's not
in medical trouble I hope you heard
anything from very well here we are you
would have been in a war with North
Korea if I didn't get elected president
remember I was good at buying one that
took us into war with my first day in
office okay here we are look at what's
happened withdrawal we're bringing
people home we're not gonna serve as
policemen all over the world I don't
want to be policemen all over the world
and yet I really built on what have you
built that before everybody recognized
him have you been able to use that
relationship to get more information
about his status ah I think the report
was incorrect let me just put it that
way
mm-hmm I think the report was done by a
network that was the thing is pointing
to see direct I'm hearing they used old
documents but I that's what I hear I
hear the report was an incorrect really
pointed to the CEO what was it an
incorrect report pointed to me just a
quick question about that so you haven't
made any contact though just to make
sure dude they're North Korea I don't
want to say I won't say that okay we had
a good relationship with North Korea as
good as you can have I mean we have a
good relationship with North Korea I
have a good relationship with Kim
jong-un and I hope he's okay and
somebody would say oh that's terrible no
it's not terrible I hope he's okay and I
think it was a fake report done by CNN
Wow
that's enough that's enough my question
the purpose you know write the truth so
you know as far as I'm concerned I want
to go I want to go to the not CNN's good
I told you CNN is fake news don't talk
to me go ahead please okay next question
first one could you talk about your
decision making process on with Georgia
generation well you know you know you
said yes Georgia your concern had a good
talk with the governor of Georgia in a
week you spoke and you did not convey
this kind of message they convey the
message I didn't like the fact that he's
leaving certain things I want the states
to open more than he does much more than
he does but I didn't like to see spa's
at this early stage you nor did the
doctors is that a correct statement
Debra I didn't like to see spas opening
frankly I didn't like to see a lot of
things happening and I wasn't happy with
it and I wasn't happy with Brian Kemp I
wasn't at all happy
Blanca's and I could have done something
about it if I wanted to but I'm saying
let the governor's do it but I wasn't
happy with Brian Kemp spas beauty
parlors tattoo parlors I know that's
that and by the way I want them to open
excuse me excuse me I want them to open
and I want him to open as soon as
possible and I got it right open but I
wasn't happy with Brian Kemp I will tell
you that right now yeah go ahead
are you surprised he to fight you on
that no no you didn't define me at all
that's your language he didn't define me
you know what happened I said you make
your own decision I told him that I said
you're not under guidelines but I'm
letting you make your own decision but I
want people to be safe and I want the
people in Georgia to be safe and I don't
want this thing to flare up because
you're deciding to do something that is
not in the guidelines and I went to
Deborah and dr. foul she and other
people worried they weren't thrilled
about it and I could have stopped him
but I decided and we all agreed they got
to watch it closely so we'll see what
happens
I told him very distinctly I said Mike
was there I said you do what you think
is best but if you ask me am i happy
about it I'm not happy about it and I'm
not happy about Brian Kemp go ahead a
question for dr. Brooks if I may mr.
president about the the rate of the
decline of the curve in the u.s. view
and the vice president tonight talking
about meaningful progress promising
progress could you speak to the rate of
decline of cases there is no information
from other countries that would inform
us about the decline yes so many of you
and I've spoken all of you from this
podium about there's weekend's
difference in reporting often a spike on
Monday if you look at Monday's over
Mondays if you look at seven-day
reporting we are starting to go down we
have a lot we had a long flat peak
largely driven a course by New York
which is about 45 or so percent of the
cases as you New York goes down so will
the rest of the country how does it find
even more accelerated I want to say
though we have had outbreaks we've had
outbreaks in specific prisons we've had
outbreaks in specific nursing homes
we've had outbreaks and specific plants
and when that happens that adds to 300
400 cases on that single date so we
track very carefully not only what the
country is doing but what each state is
doing each county is doing and we look
at Delta changes across all of the
counties so that we find early warning
signals for these types of outbreaks
because we want to prevent the whole
country to go down but we also want to
prevent the outbreaks before they are
yes thank you looking forward to
November the election given the risk but
the flute and the chronovisor could be a
problem do you think that is a risk will
be there'll be some there will be lack
of agreement like legitimacy is the
results in a very close election Wow and
people start saying goodbye whole bunch
people can go and vote I can't tell you
what's gonna happen in her life yeah I a
great question I can't tell you what's
gonna happen we have a sleepy guy in a
basement of a house that the press is
giving a free pass to who doesn't want
to do debates because of kovat and lots
of things are happening right and I
watched a couple of interviews and I say
oh I look forward to this but they're
keeping him sheltered because of the
coronavirus and he's not moving around
he's not moving too much and then I
watched what the press does to the
Republican Party and to me in particular
we had the greatest economy ever put
together we were doing this is a month
in Africa doing numbers of like the
likes of which we've never done African
Asian American Hispanic American best
employment numbers ever in the history
of our country our employment numbers
the best in the history of our country
almost a hundred and sixty million
people the stock market record numbers
many many times during my tenure many
many times but now we have a country
that we had a close because of this and
frankly if we didn't close it remember
the question was about voting in
November people possibly but certainly
we would have lost a million people you
take the high number and cut it in half
cut it in half again but whether it
would have been six hundred seven
hundred eight hundred you take a look at
at the travesty that there is you take a
look at this horrible horrible scene of
hospitals with bodies and black body
bags right multiply that times 10 15 or
even 20 question was about voting in
November so we did the right thing so
far we did the right thing so far we've
called it right we've mobilized like it
was a military operation and it was
largely a military
operation between ventilators and
testing and so many other things that
we've had a lot of good partners not all
good partners but we had a lot of good
partners gavin newsom today thanked us
very much gavin newsom california
thanked us so much and was boating in
November keep going and keep doing a
good job we got it to him today tomorrow
we're getting him even more would have
been harder for him to get it than us we
agreed to get it we got it on time he
said promises made promises kept he
actually said that in a statement today
we've done a good job we've gotten very
little credit for the great job we've
done because of the media because the
media is not an honest media in my
opinion much of it not all of it we have
some great reporters that I have
tremendous respect but much of the media
is not honest so I can't tell you about
the election we don't have a Democrat
Party and you have a large portion of
the media automatically giving the guy a
pass he's been given a pass whether or
not he's going to be the nominee I have
no idea but he's getting a pass and the
media isn't covering the great job that
we've done whether it's Mike's task
force which has been incredible it's not
been a great weather that's the way we
mobilized in a war like operation to
build these incredibly complex and very
expensive ventilators or very
ventilators are complicated question was
about voting in November the job we've
done has been an amazing job and I'm not
talking about me I'm talking about
everybody I'm talking about the generals
the Admirals Debra and Tony and and now
bill I mean something we hadn't heard
today so I can't tell you what's gonna
happen with the election I think that
had we not gone through a fake Russia
Russia Russia deal
oh now an impeachment hoax it was a
total hoax from the day I got elected
but you know it wasn't the day it was
many months before I got elected this
has been a witch hunt that was illegal
it was an illegal witch hunt it was I
think I have Pingo illegal names because
the people see we're doing a great job
and you know what we'll continue to do a
great job if we had an honest press this
country would be even greater thank you
cool handkerchief doctor Bert's arguably
the wackiest press conference so far
Donald Trump alluding to the possibility
of inserting either disinfectants or
light and heat into the inside of the
body certainly not something you would
likely have heard from Barack Obama or
from George W Bush or William Jefferson
Clinton or George HW Bush or I mean I
think you guys sort of understand
William Howard Taft maybe would have
asked about injecting bleach but I can't
say that too many other presidents would
have done that thanks to everybody for
joining me
please remember anywhere that you were
watching you can follow or like and it's
free and it really helps us in these
tough times we will be back with clips
and all of that other stuff very very
soon I appreciate you joining me today
you